yay hey guys Chris here and welcome to
my March favorites what month is it
it's April that means March favorites
always think things through out loud by
yourself in front of a camera so these
are some of the things that I loved last
month Mart somebody say I have March
Madness yeah you see if you see she said
this is Saint row fast robust robust
often saint-tropez robot st. drop it
ain't truck drop it st. robust not worth
it Helbig let's stop self 10 Express
it's a one-hour 10 a self tanner leave
me alone son I'm an independent woman
when I look at the Sun
when I was in New York doing some press
for the grace Helbig show I used some of
this stuff and it worked really well I
wanted to be Tanner than I was on
account of my susceptibility to what
society thinks is cool looking happens
to the best of us I bought a hand
chamois one of those mitts and you put
it on you go and then you pray that it
doesn't look streaky I think it looked
really natural it went on really smooth
and without streaks using the Mitt
Romney both useful who knew and it
didn't really get on sheets or clothes
but there's a little bit but they
weren't my sheets I like my self tanners
like I like my sports fans not streaking
next that keeps you safe yeah I got this
at CBS in New York
it's a Beautyblender on a stick it's
like selfies were great in your hand but
what about a selfie stick everyone lost
their goddamn minds guess what lose my
goddamn mind over this it's great I
don't know what else to say about it
things on sticks hotdog circus
performers the band sticks are great
next this kiss - yeah this is lip glow
color Reviver balm from Dior and I did
not buy this for myself this came as a
gift from pan and ice acting coach up in
Vancouver for electrode I know girl Deb
Podolski also wonderful acting coach if
you're ever in the neighborhood of
needing an acting coach in Vancouver she
also skypes if you're not a man Coover
dead
Podolski look her up she gave Hannah and
I really sweet gifts she gave us some
Dior makeup cause she used to be a
makeup artist and I would never buy Dior
for myself because it's expensive and I
don't know what to get of it but I would
gladly take it from someone else that
gives it to me so maybe my favorite is
expensive gifts no we're going to just
go with the lip balm look it comes in
this really cute packaging that makes me
feel like I'm a rich apothecary but boom
and then I don't take care of this
already step oh and it smells nice and
it tastes not toxic and then it goes on
your lips like that look
wow so great neck that you see a case a
case yeah this actually represents a
greater concept and that is my favorite
of March has been DIY I have been
thinking I'm an interior designer I got
this glass bowl at Michael's for like
six bucks and then I got all these tiny
tiny little rubber ducks and then I put
them in this bowl and I put it on a
shelf in my living room and I'm about to
get my own goddamn show on HGTV not true
I only have a show on e the grace Helbig
show Fridays at 10:30 following the soup
this makes me feel like whoa I feel like
this says about me
whoa she's interesting she's trying hard
cute next yes she said she said you
can't stack this is a romper I got from
Zara and I love it because people think
it's fashion but in reality it's just a
denim sack I'll take it I feel like a
potato yeah yeah Keisha Keisha kicks it
goes it's okay I'm just showing off my
luggage to a camera but my house I know
I love this suitcase I got this in
Canada it's made of plastic and it is
mildly durable and has already gotten
really gross from traveling with it
twice bummer it's great because it's
really identifiable and I have to worry
about anyone stealing my luggage I feel
like it's good to design but it's not
tacky you are allowed your own opinions
yes I heard all of you go really NEX
that he said he said he said these are
ugh slippers and they're the best
goddamn things ever I got these as a
gift for being on Jimmy Fallon so maybe
my favorite is expensive gifts next you
see I can see you can see you can't see
it it's the thing
it's the grace Helbig show my television
show on E Fridays at 10:30
I like it because I should and I do and
I just want you to watch it it's fun if
you don't like fun you probably won't
like it
and that's okay cuz being sad and angry
is great but there you go there my March
favorites I hope that this video was
just the best couldn't even finish that
sentence I don't know
the sound of a tiny peen flapping in the
wind